oh we've seen how militarized gear and
sometimes give people the feeling like
there's an occupying force as opposed to
a force that's part of the community
that's protecting them and serving them
can alienate and intimidate local
residents and send the wrong message
what kind of country do we want to be
it's not enough to celebrate the ideals
and we're built on liberty for all and
justice for all and equality for all
those can't just be words on paper
I think there are police departments
that have to do some soul-searching
I think there's some communities that
have to do some soul-searching but I
think we as a country had to do some
soul-searching we can work harder as a
nation to heal the rifts that still
exist in some places between law
enforcement the people you risked your
lives to protect